of course for the first
it's the middle of the night she mother
always call you at the crack of dawn
only on my birthday so it's true your
day being a fetus yes mom I'm dating a
fetus it's kind of hard for us to get
serious with his mom always tagging
along honey you're gonna design your own
line of evening where you're the Picasso
of design look yeah well Picasso didn't
have two decades of credit-card debt
you're engaged why didn't you tell me
you want to try not look it doesn't fit
come at a fork Oh your soulmate is out
there you'll find him when the time is
right frozen strawberry daiquiri please
I moved out here a week ago I'm hoping
to get discovered accurate rock star
rock star obviously oh I remember you
the rock star the truth is I'm tone-deaf
oh say it isn't so some people are meant
to just help the words
you think you're so incredibly unique
it's called living in the moment and
maybe you should give it a try
[Music]
you've always been clear that you never
wanted to get married but he does this
is a key to my house that's my birthday
present
[Music]
men don't fall in love with women who
don't take themselves seriously it's
hard for me to find someone I want to
spend the weekend with let alone the
rest of my life
[Music]
you